How would exercise congest the lymph?
Well, exercise is going to increase circulation.
And then increase circulation is going
to be dilation of your blood vessels.
And you'll increase capillary leakage.
You're hydrating the tissue.
And your muscles are calling for energy.
So you need to increase the blood supply to the muscles.
So you're going to have more fluid that's
going to need to be carried away than also.
So exercise is good for lymph low too.
But if you've had surgery and it's blocking some of the pathways,
then that could be an issue.
So typically you want to do exercise to improve lymph low
because you're contracting muscles and your moving the blood.
And it's so good for every part of your body.
But if you've had surgery that is damaged,
that is put basically a dam in the stream,
that could be an issue.
So it's really the change.
So let's say, well, I haven't done any exercise
that I don't normally do, then that's not it.
But if it's like, well, yeah, I was doing,
I had to go and do this.
I was working out the garden.
I was clearing this or something.
I guess I did do a whole bunch more exercise than before.
That could be it.
So if it isn't anything, then if it's normal,
things, nothing is changed, then I wouldn't say that would be it.
But if there was a major change, that could be a factor.
If I massage every day, but also work out,
will I maintain the status quo?
Yes, I'll let you know if something is not good.
So it's really be the change.
And you can have an infection that you, you know,
maybe is some clinical.
So if you have a little cold or something like that,
that can be an issue.
You don't realize that they're swelling that's involved.